welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Iron Man 3 kicked off a new
phase of Marvel with the craziest
application of Tony Stark's tech and a
conclusion so final that it was
completely ignored by the five Iron Man
movies that followed but there was
actually way more to appreciate in Iron
Man 3 hidden easter eggs subtle clues or
future MCU films that I only realised
after more obsessive re-examination in
this infinity saga rewatched so let's
get started with the opening lines the
famous man once said we create our own
demons who said that what does that even
mean doesn't matter I don't I'm gonna
start again the movies post-credits
scene reveals that Tony's audience is
Bruce Banner this whole movie is Tony
and Bruce trying to process what
happened in the Avengers Bruce's
responses to sleep he'll get a long nap
after age of Ultron Tony meanwhile
rambles through this weird story of
trauma and guilt
the famous Manny's paraphrase in here is
Oscar Wilde who said we are each our own
devil and we make this world our hell as
the creator of his own hell Tony now
wonders what responsibilities should we
bear for the destruction our creations
wreak on the world this movie actually
poses two answers retirement but we know
that's [ __ ] really the answer is
mentorship I actually think there's a
secret meaning to this post-credits
scene that we will discuss that the
climax of a well structured video essay
but we open on Bern 1999 with the return
of yinsen because this is the tech
conference he referenced in the first
Ironman we met once you know I had a
technical conference and I don't
remember
Oh were you wouldn't if I had been that
drunk I wouldn't have been able to stand
much less give a lecture and there's
lots of 90s nostalgia Eiffel 65 s blue
and happy oguns look is modeled on John
Travolta from pulp fiction
Tony's with Maya Hansen in the comics
she co creates the extremis virus
alongside Aldrich Killian who also shows
up here retconned in the MCU to be the
founder of aim which in the comics is a
separate offshoot of Hydra Tony makes my
antique aliens card because he doesn't
like being handed things as we saw in
the Avengers I don't like being handed
things because I love to be handed in an
Iron Man - yikes he doesn't like to be
handed think I have a plan Tony's name
tag reads you know who I am previously
he wore a black sabbath's shirt whose
song I am Iron Man was also a callback
to his big reveal notice Tony's
sunglasses in this foam he uses them to
shield unwanted interactions and then
dramatically takes them off to show
aggression as he does in finiti war but
he also takes them off to share them
with minds he respects Maya here and in
spider-man far from home Peter Parker
the future protege I believe this whole
movie is secretly Tony's training wheels
protocol for Tony fails to nurture the
nerd Killian who like Maya's plants
transforms into a bomb and Killian is
framed with fireworks here foreshadowing
the explosive fireworks finale Tony now
tests his new mark 42 armor controlled
via microchips in his blood the first
step in the armors evolution toward the
bleeding edge armor from the comics
which pulls out from its flesh the mark
85 nanotech never actually resides in
his bloodstream though it's Christmas
time director Shane Black often sets his
movies at Christmas time and Tony's
opening words back in the Avengers
setting us up Christmas but
me and when the facemask locks in notice
the impact causes a bit of blood to
trickle from his limp as Vanko told him
in Iron Man 2 if you can lead people
will cease to believe in him and in this
movie Tony ceases to believe in himself
the mandarins TV broadcast opens with
the logo of the ten rings which we saw
in Roz's banner in the first movie
Mandarin in this movie is a false flag
an actor Trevor Slattery appropriating
the Mandarin legend the real Mandarin
will be played by Tony Leung in Shanxi
in the legend of the ten rings and the
Marvel one-shot all hail the king
cleared up Slattery's fakery there's
somebody who wants to meet you know you
took his name and now he wants it back
that is why the imagery here is such a
chaotic mismatch of cultural influences
they draw on the jihad' messaging of
Osama bin Laden but he also cites the
real-life history of the Sand Creek
Massacre in 1864 in the trailer you can
see all says a neck tattoo showing cap
shield emblazoned with an anarchy a so a
little lesson for you anything that's a
lot of something it's probably nothing
of anything the president in the MCU is
Matthew Ellis a nod to Warren Ellis who
wrote the extremist storyline in the
Iron Man comics and Rhodey is now iron
patriot who in the comics is the
patriotic armor worn by Norman Osborn in
the briefing near hits at the redesign
was done by aim
Killians company Tony tells Rhodey about
his sleepless tinkering I got bomb
disposal caches explosions midair Casey
mr. Tony made tech to catch a missile in
midair and disposed it so that he will
never again have to fly a nuke through a
terrifying Hellmouth Tony gets a panic
attack because the little Nerds drawing
is so shitty and loved you in A
Christmas Story by the way Tony's
referencing Peter Billingsley who grew
up into a film producer and Favreau
collaborator and plays X dark engineer
William get to Reba and the MCU who has
a big role in spider-man's future of
returning in far from home happy Nags
pepper the human element of human
resources is our biggest point of
vulnerability we should start phasing it
out immediately what an overreaction but
another example of the recurring human
versus technology conflict that runs
throughout these films Killian flakiest
Savin based on Eric Savin from the
comics the villain cold-blood a cyborg
assassin later Tony will nickname him
West world back home tony has hunga
stalking for Jarvis which is red green
and yellow maybe a nod to the
comics color scheme of his future format
a vision Kevin Feige described this
movie as a love triangle between pepper
Tony and Tony's obsession with his armor
and that is on full display here is Tony
tricks pepper with the empty mark 42
which also sets up the reveal of Tony
remotely saving the following people
with this armor later Tony jokes I got a
team of guys coming tomorrow they're
gonna blow up that wall actually the
next day Tony does dare a team of guy to
blow out that wall
I love how in all three Iron Man movies
Tony's Malibu mansion gets increasingly
smashed up until in this third movie
it's fully demolished reflecting how
Tony's vanity is being stripped away
Tony's new sculpture is made up of
pieces of the wrecked Formula one cars
from Monaco another running joke that's
easily missed here in Iron Man 1 Tony
demanded pepper by overpriced art and
then in Iron Man 2 he sold the
collection as a tax write-off now in
Iron Man 3 he refills his collection
with the broken pieces of the chaos in
his wake Tony's nightmare triggers his
suit and peppers pajama shirt is the
same I lost an electron are you positive
joke shirt that Peter Parker later wears
while visiting Tony and spider-man
homecoming you know there's probably
like an Oedipus complex episode of total
conspiracy here but I don't have time
for it anthe Hollywood Chinese Theater 7
meets with extremis patient Taggert
named after Jack Taggert in the comics
who becomes fire power nearby in this
four quarter actually the hem prints of
Robert Downey jr. as he walks away
noticed the music
this is the famous deus array funeral
theme that composers used for a ton of
films to evoke doom use memorably in the
opening theme of The Shining wounded by
the explosion happy points to Taggarts
dog tags a clue that Tony channels is
alternate universe Sherlock Holmes to
decode there's actually a fun callback
with this point later when happy points
to the TV playing Downton Abbey after
threatening the Mandarin Maya appears at
Tony's home
you're not the Mandarin are you are you
interesting now Maya never answers that
question a hint that she is still
working for aim and Killian who are
funding the Mandarin campaign
Tony summons the mark 42 armor to
protect pepper giving us our first hint
of pepper in the rescue armor and
Avengers endgame and when Tony lands in
Tennessee he rubs snow on his left arm
Tony's left arm it's kind of a recurring
injury he broke it in the past
and now his recent implants have
ruptured Tony breaks into the garage of
Harley keiner
a whiz kid who actually returns for
Tony's funeral and Avengers in game
alakina it's been brought up as a
potential iron lad figure in future
films the newspaper uses a photo of Tony
from his Senate Harry in Iron Man 2 and
the Leipsic photo of the suit repurposed
for the newspaper photo in the first
movie Pepper finds Tony's recorded
message for her inside one of his old
helmets setting up the way Tony will
leave post mortem messages for pepper
and in-game and even though the Mandarin
in this movie ain't the real Mandarin
Slattery's costume does include the ten
rings the one on his right pinky is the
same one Raza wore in Iron Man Shane she
will likely reveal the actual ten rings
and how they're McLuhan tech with mystic
powers
Harley triggers Tony's panic attack by
comparing the blast crater to the
hellmouth wormhole 6:10 only five
shadows yeah people said these shadows
are like the marks of souls going to
heaven set the bomb guy
what the hell kind of he didn't get a
shadow hey six victims only five going
to heaven this is the math of Tony's
greatest fear that his self destruction
will cause the deaths of the six
Avengers but he will be trapped in the
hell of his own making
yeah Tony that ac/dc gain is fun when
it's on Mythbusters awesome mix yeah so
when Tony tells Chad Davis's mom that
her son wasn't a murderer he's as much
reassuring the family of an innocent
victim as he is himself they're attacked
by another extremist soldier Ellen Brant
in the comics the ex-wife and villain to
man-thing Brandt's facial scarring here
could be a reference to the acid
scarring from man-thing in the comics
Savan takes hardly he was trying to say
I want my goddamn file that's your fault
kid
assuming Tony's relationship with Harley
is training wheels protocol for his
mentorship of Peter Parker these words
are deeply ironic you start flattery
execute son like TV an accountant for
the Roxxon corporation the recurring
energy conglomerate of the Marvel world
later the oil tanker is a Roxxon one
Stanley judges the pageant and Tony
hacks a news truck with the help of
comedian Adam Paley as Gary
another nerdy wannabe that Tony must
learn how to mentor meanwhile Maya
brings have Wernher von Braun before he
built rockets for the Nazis hey
idealistic Wernher von Braun dreamed of
space travel star gazed von Braun was
one of the idealists who inspired Howard
and Tony who similarly built weapons and
later aimed Aztecas the stars
fun fact von Braun was one of the German
scientists recruited by the u.s. after
the war in Operation Paperclip the same
program that allowed Arnim Zola to
corrupt shield after his third panic
attack Harley tells Tony to just build
something inspiring Tony to cure himself
the same way he has in the past engineer
a solution from boxing class after
learning the truth in Killians compound
they reference Thor it was just that big
dude with a hammer fell out of the sky
subtlety's kind of had his day
Tony references Thor 2 with the mark 42
pieces delayed just like how many linear
was for Thor when he's fighting Hulk
this ponytail Express guard is the same
actor from bacos prison cell in Iron Man
2 and the other guard has the movie's
best line honestly I hate working here
they are so weird this guy is Eric Orem
Robert Downey jr. is fight choreographer
for the Marvel and Sherlock Holmes films
fully suited up Tony hilariously walks
downstairs and he awesomely uses the
mark 42 to barrel of monkeys the people
and they blow off a fisherman's hat one
of my favorite tropes that we also saw
in the first Ironman
now this shipyard rescue is accompanied
by the house party protocol dozens of
Iron Man suits and we got to break down
which of them we can see down baby
alright first up is a March 17
heartbreaker named for its enlarged
chest repulsor Tony uses it to break
Rody's heart later arriving alright
breakers left looks like the mark 39
star boost suborbital suit capable of
spaceflight star boots definitely shows
up later and to the left of that one is
the mark 33 silver Centurion the first
suit Tony suits up and in this battle
known for its polygonal shape and its
hidden blades that Tony used to cut off
Killians arm and the left it's silver
Centurion is a moriki suit the last suit
Tony wears in the battle jumping in
after blowing up Killian at that point
that's missing a leg would happen to it
when they were no sliding over to the
right of heartbreaker is the mark 13
armor ain't much to say about that one
and to the right of that one the mark 35
red snapper suit which gets decapitated
it has these long pincer-like claws into
the right of red snapper is the mark 27
disco it's got a bold red on blue color
scheme speaking of blue the next shot
shows three more flowing ones the mark
30 blue steel and two speed based suits
the mark 21 - and the mark 19 tiger like
that one I think that God's care of and
Baskins husband on its breath and then
there's a sighting for the mark 37
hammerhead suit with its teal color
pressurized bulk for use underwater then
Tony orders the house party to take him
to church
the first to dive in is the mark 31
piston suits piston also gets torn apart
later in battle one of the coolest suits
is a mark 41 bones suits black and gold
design and the 41 be the prototype of
the mark 42 it disassembles and
reassembles its parts now the big boy is
mark 38 Igor suit used for delivering
heavy loads its design is believed to be
a precursor of the Hulkbuster armor
revealed needs Voltron and then there's
a mark 25 straight with yellow and black
jackhammer arms then after leaving the
silver Centurion Tony tries to jump in
the mark 22 hot rod named after those
flame boots like Tony's Ford Roadster it
was designed to be a new war machine
prototype but yeah the hot ride it's
immediately destroyed then Tony suits up
in the mark 16 nightclub but then the
jacks right before killing punches
through it and then chops on the mark 40
shotgun powerful repulsors backhanded
Killian achillion slice up its leg hits
him with it and then he is slice it in
half then the mark 42 returns and for
the third time in the movie had
hilariously shatters but like Tony its
brokenness ends up being its secret
weapon because Tony uses it to assemble
around Killian a bull Mont doing this
Tony gives the enemy what he always
wanted and dooms him with the burden of
that power like Jafar in Aladdin
in the final suit is the mark 8 which
pepper takes down now this would have
been the first new model of armor Tony
built after the mark 7 and Avengers
meaning that pepper here uproots the
beginning of tony's obsessive taking
face she's a corner the triangle that
wins I mentioned earlier how Tony sliced
off Killians arm
Feige actually worked an amputation into
each phase to film as a nod to the
amputation trope in the Star Wars movies
and of course Killian has these dragon
tattoos appropriate in the Mandarin
title for himself dumb of said that the
dragon imagery is a nod to the Ironman
villian Fin Fang Foom but you know the
dragon is also just a recurring Chinese
symbol with multiple associations maybe
do some homework dragons can mean
multiple things and with the clean slate
protocol Tony transforms his broken suit
recurring nightmare into victorious
fireworks the cardiologist dr. Wu that
he brushed off the prologue returns
surgically removing the shrapnel from
Tony's chest showing how Tony evolved
from ignoring conference guests like
insin and Killian to Letty and others
help him Antoni uses these shrapnel
pieces to make a necklace for pepper
reflecting away Tony repurposes scraps
whether it's cave junk or scrap arts for
his heart paperweight santé Tony also
hooks up Harley with a new workshop
including a potato gun mark - and a
replacement limited edition door they
explore a watch for his sister our final
image shows Tony littering his removed
arc reactor detaching himself from the
armor and choosing pepper over Iron Man
well until he decides to be Iron Man
again in a couple years let's take
another look at that post-credit scene
it's like a snake swallowing its own
tail everything comes full circle where
did I lose you
elevator in Switzerland so you heard
none of it you know now that I think
about it Oh God my original wound 1983
all right 14 years old I still have a
nanny that was weird
remember in the beginning Tony told
banner I'm gonna start again yeah Tony's
not the most reliable narrator is he
he's questioning himself revising his
story yeah there's enough grounds here
to interpret the Iron Man three final
scene as Tony's fantasy his dream
scenario for how he wishes he could walk
away from all this because if he was
truly at peace why the need for endless
therapy now to be clear Iron Man 3
happened in the MCU Tony built dozens of
suits
Tony fought kilee and all that happened
but this narratives fictitious nature
makes Tony's conclusion
definitely up for interpretation the
lesson is not retirement but mentorship
Tony ignored gifted fanboys until they
grew into syndrome styled demons but by
sharing his wisdom with the Nerds
Tony learns exactly what to do when he
finds the MCS biggest nerd
give him pepper shirt do you believe the
Iron Man 3 ending was real comment down
below and join our watch Long's on this
score by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash new rockstars follow
me on Instagram and Twitter a da vas
follow new rockstars and subscribe to
have all your nerdy questions answered
questions like can I have my shoe back
[Music]